after an early surprise the full
PlayStation Plus lineup for the new
month has been announced if you're a
subscriber and want to know what you can
play for free in June I've got you
covered the first game is available to
download right now it's Call of Duty
World War 2 the 2017 shooter is known
for a strong single-player campaign and
the multiplayer servers are still up and
running
there are traditional multiplayer modes
to jump into but world war 2 also
includes war mode which has its own
story and competitive objectives to
complete the battle continues with ps4 s
other free game Star Wars Battlefront 2
it's another 2017 game but it's changed
a lot since launch with tons of new game
modes maps and characters all the way up
to rise of Skywalker the last content
update was released earlier this year
but there will still be double xp
weekends and endgame challenges in the
future for new players and those are
your free PlayStation Plus games for
June you can grab call of duty right now
but you'll have to wait until June 2nd
for Star Wars they'll both be available
until July 6 remember that you can
always check out gameplay clips and
reviews for these titles on GameSpot and
stay tuned as we report on the new PS
Plus lineup every month
[Music]
you